[موسيقى]
هذه القنابل التي تسمى جي ال اس دي بي
وتعني القنابل صغيره القطر التي يتم
اطلاقها من الارض قنابل تصنع بالاشتراك
بين شركه ساب السويديه وشركه بوينج
الامريكيه هذه القنبله تتميز بانها تجمع
بين قدرات القنابل الصغيره والتي تلقى من
الطائرات ومحرك الصاروخ الارضي ام 26
[موسيقى]
تطلق هذه القنبله من رجمه هاي مارس ثم عن
طريق المحرك الصاروخي تصل الى ارتفاع محدد
ومن ثم تقوم بالانزلاق نحو الهدف كما
يمكنها الالتفاف حول التضاريس الجبليه بل
وتخطي الدفاعات الجويه للعدو على خلاف
القنابل التقليديه التي تتجه مباشره نحو
الهدف
هذه القنبله مزوده ايضا بتكنولوجيا اعاده
البرمجه كما انها تتميز بخاصيه التغلب على
التشويش الالكتروني والقدره على المناوره
لضرب الهدف من زاويه منخفضه او مرتفعه
[موسيقى]